President Trump does an epically chaotic
press conference Democrats keep on
pushing against wall funding and
internecine warfare breaks out in both
parties i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
man the president has had himself a busy
twitter day and I will get to all of it
in just one second some of it is pretty
fantastic don't worry we'll break it all
down for you in just a sec but first we
need to talk about your mouth
cleanliness your mouth help okay so most
people don't worry too much about the
health of their teeth but the truth is
that if you are not keeping a healthy
mouth and you're probably not keeping a
healthy body the fact is that tooth
decay is linked to things including
heart disease which is one of the
reasons why you ought to have a really
nice toothbrush well the best toothbrush
on the market for your money is
certainly quipped I know it's what I use
every single day there's a photo of me
recently in Vanity Fair my teeth look
spectacular you wonder why well that is
because I use quip every single day
twice a day why what does quip do for me
well it has sensitive sonic vibrations
for an effective clean that is gentle on
your sensitive gums it has a built-in
two-minute timer pulse which means that
you usually brush for like 20 seconds
then you throw the toothbrush down and
walk away frustrating well this makes
sure equip makes sure that you are
brushing for the necessary allotted
amount of time they've got a multi-use
cover that works as a stand and mounts
mirrors and slides over your bristles to
pack and protects quick I'm gonna go
quip is the best electric toothbrush
also because you don't have to use those
crazy charging stands that you have to
bring with you on the road brush heads
are automatically delivered to you new
brush heads on a regular basis as well
so you never have to worry about that
again quip is wonderful and that's why
over a million happy healthy people have
quit right now it starts at just 25
bucks if you go to get quipped comm
slash capiro right now you get your
first refill pack for free that is once
again get quick calm slash Shapiro GE t
qu IP comm slash appear on get your
first refill pack free over there get
equip comm slash repair I'll go check it
out right now okay so yesterday
President Trump did an epically chaotic
press conference and it was you know it
was the full Trump he brought it all he
was in new year and that man came ready
to play he's been ready to play on
Twitter all day long he he opened this
morning actually by retweeting a daily
wire meme that we put out a couple of
weeks ago a couple of months ago maybe
about Elizabeth Warren that showed
Elizabeth Warren's 2020 logo but it said
Elizabeth Warren one out of 20 xx
mocking the fact that she pretends to be
one out of 1024 Native American
president Trump retweeted that today
with our watermarks that's pretty
spectacular ah this is this is our world
and it's wonderful it's a wonderful
wonderful world it wasn't just that
President Trump also did a press
conference yesterday the dude loves
memes I mean one thing you have to hand
President Trump is this is one
entertaining dude how do you know this
well he did his press conference and at
this press conference he is sitting
there I believe it's in the Roosevelt
Room and he's got his his beautiful his
beautiful large table and right there in
the center of his beautiful large table
is a giant 11 by 14 piece of color
photocopy of a meme of him that says
sanctions are coming as in winter is
coming from Game of Thrones
now the sanctions it didn't reference
like what the sanctions would be about
or against whom or why this is on the
table and he never mentions it the
entire press conference he does an
entire press conference with a meme of
himself that says sanctions are coming
in front of him in a game of Thrones
pose and no one says anything about it
and nobody nobody asked him a question
about it nobody says what the hell is
this doing here what does this mean
he never references it he never says you
know why this is out is because I
thought it was great and because I'm
using sanctions against Russia or Iran
or North Korea no instead he just sort
of sits there and we all just accept it
like it's it's like an easter egg in the
middle of life it's spectacular
okay so president Trump is doing this
entire press conference it was a wild
press conference by the way it was
supposed to be theoretically about the
wall it did not end up being about to
all it ended up being about foreign
policy it had its ups and it had its
down it was an epic epic episode of good
Trump bad Trump the president said some
things that were quite good he said some
things that were quite bad this is why
you know him and this is why you love
him so here was President Trump on
foreign policy here was something good
that he said he was asked about European
disapproval that right now his approval
numbers in Europe are extraordinarily
low and the correct answer to this
question is who cares they're European
and President Trump gets this one right
he says who cares they're European where
they say I'm not popular in Europe I
shouldn't be popular in Europe if I was
popular in Europe I wouldn't be doing my
job because I want Europe to pay I'm not
elected by Europeans I'm elected by
Americans and by American taxpayers
frankly I wouldn't say they're thrilled
because they've had many many years
where they didn't have to pay so now
they're gonna have to pay and if that
makes me unpopular
country's that's okay but we're doing
tremendous service to those countries
and they should at least respect us I
love when president Trump then continued
and he said if I were running for office
in any of those European countries I'd
win which is just spectacular Trump I
mean that is top-shelf Trump and of
course he's right about all of this and
it is really stupid to suggest that we
need the approval of the Europeans to
run our own foreign policy MIT Romney
had written in his foolish editorial in
The Washington Post that the Europeans
had far more confidence in our foreign
policy under President Obama than
president Trump right because their
priorities were President Obama's
priorities whereas American priorities
are president Trump's priorities this is
a winning point for the president this
is the reason that he was elected
specifically because people felt that
President Obama had not done a good job
of representing American interests at
home and abroad and president Trump was
going to at least put American interest
first I mean this was one of his
campaign slogans so that was really good
then President Trump got to his actual
policy now I wish that there were a link
between President Trump's rhetoric about
putting America first and his actual
policy because I think that his policy
is in many cases wrong and I think that
his view of the world is in many cases
wrong so I appreciate the attitude which
is that America's interests are
paramount I don't necessarily think it
links up with his policy however so
President Trump was trying to justify
his policy in Syria now suffice it to
say there is a complex case that can be
made for his policy in Syria there is an
editorial that I read recently that was
from an actual member of the Obama
administration praising President
Trump's decision to pull out of Syria
suggesting that it would sort of thrust
regional responsibilities onto the Turks
and so the Russians ons the Syrians that
no solution was going to be reached with
regard to northern Syria or Kurdistan
without Turkish buy-in so trying to lock
the Turks out would be a mistake suffice
it to say I think that logic is wrong I
think that the the Turkish government
right now run by received type irawan is
one of the worst governments in the
world it's it's really a truly awful
government Iran is a is a dictatorial
autocratic thug
he's ripped every pretense of democracy
away from his nation and trying to
pretend that Turkish interests our
American interests are foolish trying to
pretend Russian interests in the area
our American interest that's foolish to
trying to pretend that the Syrians have
any interest in either wiping out Isis
or in establishing any sort of stability
that doesn't make them a proxy of Iran
that's foolhardy as well but president
Trump tries to justify his policy in
I will say this about President Trump
President Trump does have a good for
aphorism there's no question that the
man has a real gift for being able to
encapsulate his ideas in very short and
convincing sentences but I don't think
that this is an actual policy what he's
about to say about Syria Syria was lost
long ago it was lost long ago and
besides that I don't what we're talking
about sand and death that's what we're
talking about we're not talking about
you know vast wealth we're talking about
sand and death okay so I'm not sure
whether if there were vast wealth there
that would really change our calculus
very much the reason we are in Syria
presumably is to fight Isis he's not
wrong Syria is a tinderbox Syria is a
lot of sand and a lot of death but that
doesn't mean that death can't be
exported to other places that's the
reason we were there in the first place
that's the reason we were to rock in the
first place so when President Trump says
that Syria was lost long ago that's true
the the Obama administration made
certain that Syria's regime would not be
toppled that was the case since 2011
2012 2013
but when President from sort of ignores
the ongoing American responsibility to
both our Kurdish allies and to citizens
around the world American citizens who
ought to and have right to be concerned
about the continued rise of Isis in
northeastern Syria you know that that is
a point of ignorance so again I like
president Trump's america-first
perspective I don't necessarily think
that it translates into a solid policy
that became particularly true when
President Trump talked about issues of
history so you don't need to be a
historical scholar to achieve the right
answer on foreign policy but sometimes
it helps it means that you are less
gullible it means you are less likely to
fall for a self flattering version of
history pushed by revisionist historians
though the Russians are the leading
revisionist historians on planet earth
right now every intervention in which
they've ever engaged was apparently
justified Vladimir Putin sounds like he
was whispering into president Trump's
ear when President Trump talked
yesterday about the situation in
Afghanistan he basically suggested that
he was interested in pulling out from
Afghanistan and then he made a very
weird move he started talking about why
the Russians need to be involved in
Afghanistan and he defended the 1979
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan now I
don't know why he would do that I will
I would listen to a drunk history
podcast with President Trump doing
history because this does not bear any
relationship with reality what he's
about to say and the fact that you have
a Republican president who's now
praising the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan which lest we forget
happened under Jimmy Carter and led
directly to the election of Geron old
Reagan in 1980 why a Republican
president would now be praising the
policies of Leonid Brezhnev that's
beyond me but here's President Trump
defending the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan I guess to defend the idea
that we should thrust responsibility for
Afghanistan on the Russians maybe
something like that in Afghanistan was
because terrorists were going into
Russia they were right to be there the
problem is it was a tough fight and
literally they went bankrupt they went
into being called Russia again as
opposed to the Soviet Union you know a
lot of a lot of these places you're
reading about now are no longer part of
Russia because of Afghanistan okay that
is uh I'm not sure there's a thing there
that's true so number one Russia did not
go into Afghanistan because of terrorism
okay the rise of radical Islamic
terrorism in Afghanistan and today it
will post dates the the Russian leaving
of FK understand and the American
leaving with Afghanistan right the rise
of Osama bin Laden happened in the
aftermath of the Mujahideen driving the
Russians out of Afghanistan in in the
first place
the reason that Afghanistan was invaded
by the Russians is because the Russians
cooed the legitimate government of
Afghanistan and put in place a communist
government of Afghanistan which was then
attempted there's an attempted rebellion
in Afghanistan and the Russians at the
behest of their communist puppet
government went in and occupied the
country that's the reason the Russians
were in Afghanistan the this notion that
the Russians went in there because of
terrorism their right to be there is in
almost insane one okay it's just
patently historically illiterate it is
not true in the slightest and when the
president says that Afghanistan drove
the Soviets bankrupt it damaged the
Soviet capacity to war mostly damaged
them in terms of public relations and
meant that all of the fringe nations on
the edges of the Soviet Union looked at
the Russians and they said well you
don't really have the capacity to keep
us here so if we feel like leaving we're
just going to leave but to say that
Afghanistan is what drove the Soviets
bankrupted communism drove the Soviets
bankrupt Afghanistan was just a symptom
of the Soviet
crup see that had already taken place
now why does any of this matter I'll
explain it just like why isn't it just
president Trump mouthing off I'll
explain in just one second first let's
talk about how you can make your
business better so let's say that you
are the President of the United States
and you're looking for a me but the
people who you have tasked to get that
name are not good enough to find you a
fantastic day lee weyer maybe they're
not good enough to find you a sanctions
are coming Mimi you can just put on your
desk in the middle of a press conference
you need better employees you need zip
recruiter if the federal government use
zip recruiter there would not be so many
non-essential employees working for the
federal government we here at the Daily
wire use a zip recruiter on a regular
basis
zip recruiter allows you to find the
best employees in the shortest possible
amount of time you know what smart
starting off the new year strong by
going to zip recruiters calm slash daily
wire and hire the right people unlike
other job sides if worker finds
qualified candidates for you it's
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and actively invites them to
your jobs you get qualified candidates
fast this is why zip recruiter is rated
number one by employers in the United
States that rating comes from hiring
sites on trust pilot with over a
thousand reviews right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free at zip
recruit comm slash daily wire again that
zip recruiter comm slash daily Wire Dai
ly w I re that zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire if you are looking
to improve your business there is no
excuse not to use zip recruiter which is
why we here use it at the Daily wire
offices and everyone feels on
tenterhooks perhaps you'll replace them
with an employee gathered from zip
recruiter keeps everyone on their toes
keeps in a pressure pill the pressure
filled environment but also a relaxed
friendly environment because our
employees are great because we got them
with zip recruiters comm slash daily
wired go check them out right now zip
recruiter comm slash daily wear okay so
president Trump sounds off about the
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan so why
exactly does any of that matter because
he is using that as backdrops why it
wouldn't be bad for the Russians to go
back into Afghanistan okay that's not
great the Russians when they went into
Afghanistan the reason the United States
opposed that is because there is a
theory that
embolden in the Russian sphere of
influence broadening the Russian sphere
of influence would be bad for the United
States providing them more material
resources providing them more
territorial control allowing them to
expand their base of resources would be
a bad idea
and this is right this is Ronald
Reagan's policy suggest
saying that the Russians were right to
be in Afghanistan it's sort of leads to
the logic the Russians are right to be
in Ukraine that they'd be right to be in
in Kazakhstan that they'd be right to be
in Estonia or Latvia or Lithuania the
fact is that president Trump's
historical knowledge is not up to par on
this particular issue and that informs a
foreign policy that seems ignorance on
particular areas now again you don't
have to be a student of history or
enough to know a lot about the Soviet
invasion of Afghanistan to know that
it's probably a bad idea to let Vladimir
Putin expand his territorial base around
the world that's probably a bad idea if
it was a bad idea for President Obama to
give Syria over to Putin it's a bad idea
to give Afghanistan over its Putin right
this would all be a bad move but it
certainly helps when you're not watching
history to this extent that wasn't the
the extent of the bad Trump in this
press conference President President
Trump also went after General James
Madison critera of Defense who just left
now I will say I think the media royally
Mis covered the mattis situation they
made it seem like James Madison's
leaving specifically over Syria that he
was very angry the president Trump was
pulling over Syria apparently there been
tensions between the two for quite a
while
apparently mattis was very close with
the then chief of staff John Kelly and
the two of them were sort of a clique
inside the White House that was opposed
to the Secretary of State that was
opposed to the National Security Adviser
that was opposed to Jared Kushner's
office that as opposed to other members
of the cabinet with all of that said
when Madison
president Trump's best move would have
been to just say well thank you for
service general I'll see you later
and if mattis has a couple of parting
shots on the way out well that's the way
it goes nobody really cares everybody
moves on with their life instead
president Trump has never been a man to
take anything lying down and so here as
president from slamming James Madison as
his exit from the White House
general mattis thanked me profusely for
getting him seven hundred billion
dollars he couldn't believe it general
mattis thanked me even more the
following year when I got him 716
billion dollars he couldn't believe it
because our military was depleted but
general mattis was so thrilled but
what's he done for me how has he done in
Afghanistan not too good
not too good I'm not happy with what
he's done in Afghanistan and I shouldn't
be happy ok slamming his own Secretary
of Defense who
didn't fire who resigned again not a
good look if President Trump picked the
best people why exactly is he slamming
the guy that he picked and one of his
most popular cabinet members from the
moment that he was named to the time
that he left I'm president Trump has a
habit of fighting back but you got to
pick your spots you really do have to
pick your spots that was not in fact the
funniest thing that President Trump said
about the military in the middle of this
particular press conference so President
Trump also decided that he would go off
on his own military experience which is
never a bright move for the president
here's the president saying that he
thinks that he would have been a good
general based on here he is it's the
craziest thing I've ever seen I think I
would have been a good general but who
knows well I mean who knows okay look
here's the thing when President Trump is
like this when President Trump does this
sort of thing it does raise the question
as to how much his personality is
impacting his policy decisions whether
it's personal animus that is driving his
decision-making on Syria or on
Afghanistan whether it's his personal
like for kim jeong-hoon that is driving
his policy on kim jeong-hoon what's the
separation between personality and
policy and the answer for Trump is I
think not much I think that personality
does Drive his policy in many ways and
that means that he is reacting the
circumstances around him sometimes for
bad but sometimes for good and this
brings us to some good Trump so
President Trump I do not think he's
doing the wrong thing when it comes to
this government shutdown over the wall I
don't think the president Trump it
should be blamed for the fact that
Democrats are not willing to give him
the money that he needs to install some
sort of physical barrier on the southern
border to prevent mass immigration from
south of the border illegally into the
United States it doesn't seem like a lot
to ask
it's just be real about this we have a
22 trillion dollar deficit in this
country the Democrats pretending to be
fiscally responsible is a joke it is
ridiculous it is silly it is not real
they have spending priorities that
include funding Sesame Street but not
the actual border wall on the southern
border that will protect people from
being murdered inside the United States
by you know whatever number of criminal
illegal aliens actually cross the
president Trump is not wrong to do any
of this so when President Trump speaks
out about it his stubbornness is an
asset so stubbornness as we all know
from people that we know from our
parents from our
when your friend is stubborn in your
defense it's really good when your
friend is stubborn being a dummy that's
really bad well president Trump is
stubborn both ways and so we've seen him
earlier in the show be a little bit
foolish with regard to more than a
little bit foolish with regard to Soviet
policy or if regard to Syria north
regard to General James Madison's to him
being stubborn on the wall this is where
the stubbornness can be utilized in a
good way this is where the fact that
Trump has this real stubborn streak can
pay off for conservatives so here's
President Trump explaining to Nancy
Pelosi that listen the Vatican has a
wall like you guys are whining about
walls walls work here's President Trump
explaining and he's of course exactly
right when they say the Wolves immoral
well then you better gotta do something
about the Vatican because the Vatican
has the biggest wall of them all the
wall is immoral look at all of the
countries that have walls and they work
100% it's never gonna change a wall is
at war okay he's exactly right about
this and this is a point where his
stubbornness is a natural asset this is
why he really should give a national
address president from chakal a prime
time national address on as many
networks as we'll give him the airspace
and he should say here is why we need a
wall here are the names that people have
been killed because we don't have a wall
here are the cost to our country it's
because we don't have a wall right this
would be a time for President Trump to
use that bully pulpit and really get out
there in front of the American people
and President Trump makes a pretty good
point here which is the courts gave
President Obama tremendous power to
ignore the law when it came to allowing
illegal immigrants to stay imagine if we
applied that kind of power to me I
haven't tried to seize that kind of
power but apparently the left was fine
with presidents having that kind of
power in the first place is allowed to
do what he did a doctor then I'm allowed
to do whatever I want to do on things
that you know probably a president as he
said probably a president doesn't have
the right to do okay and Trump is
exactly right about this to which his
Democrats are very comfortable with
executive power so long as the executive
power is being used on their side I
think that president rums case for the
government shutdown is is not a bad one
his case for for standing up for the
wall is actually quite a good one but he
needs to make it more forcefully than
just going on Twitter and that means
going to rallies it means speaking out
loud because
now people are actually not gonna get
paid for starting basically on Friday
people are not going to be getting their
paychecks now so I think that the
government shutdown is the end of the
world no I've never thought that the
world I've never thought that it's gonna
be the zombie apocalypse because a
certain percentage of non-essential
employees will not be paid for a couple
of weeks I don't think that's the end of
the world I don't think most Americans
really feel it I mean you're still
getting your mail you are still getting
your Social Security checks you're still
getting your Medicare coverage right
you're still getting all the things that
the federal government is there to
provide at least so far as the left
social service network is concerned so I
don't think there's a huge panic area
but it's a good point of leverage for
president trouble it's amazing though is
the media coverage so remember when Ted
Cruz was quote-unquote responsible for
shutting down the government in 2013 for
not giving Obama funding for Obamacare
the media put it online Cruz it was not
Obama's fault it was Cruz's fault so his
Congress's fault for not giving the
president what he wanted and thus
forcing a shutdown now when it's
Congress not giving the president what
he wants and thus forcing a shutdown its
president Trump's fault look at the sort
of immediate glowing glowing media
coverage to the Nancy Pelosi has been
receiving for saying that she will not
budge an inch on the wall here she was
being interviewed on Good Morning
America about the wall and she says
listen we're not gonna give a dime for
the wall
are you willing to come up and give him
some of this money for the wall because
apparently that's the sticking point
no nothing does well we're talking about
border security nothing for the wall but
that means sort of back and forth no I
think how many ways can we say no
nothing for the world
okay so where is the questioner saying
okay so you're willing to allow people
to go without paychecks right ask Nancy
Pelosi the same questions you're asking
President Trump and make her answer
whether she's willing to allow people to
go without paychecks to let national
parks shut down simply to not fund a
border wall that will keep Americans
safe it's pretty incredible it really is
and a second I'm gonna show you how the
media continued to play defense for the
Democrats even in a situation where they
would never do anything similar for
Republicans of course of course but
first let's talk about your sleep
quality so when you go to sleep every
night you think about the comfort level
of your mattress you think about the
temperature in your room but how often
you think about your sheets the answer
is probably you don't think about your
sheets all that often because well why
would you accept that that's probably
the reason you are not getting a better
sleep you need a better set of sheets
and that's where ball and branch comes
in
everything that bulletin branch makes
from bedding to blankets is made from
pure 100% organic cotton
it means they start out super soft and
they get even softer over time you can
buy directly from bull and branch so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices I love my ball and bran sheets
they're so good then I threw out all my
other sheets and got only Boleyn branch
because after you've slept on bull and
branch sheets it's sort of ruins all
other sheets for you luxury sheets again
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store bull and branch sheets just a
couple of hundred bucks even three u.s.
presidents sleep on bull and branch
sheets shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights if you don't love them
send them back for a refund but you're
not gonna want to send them back to get
you started right now my listeners get
50 bucks off your first set of sheets at
bowl and branch calm promoter Ben that's
bull and branch calm promo code Ben
again bull and branch calm promo code
been 450 bucks off your first set of
sheets that's bol and branch calm promo
code Ben today there's a reason that my
wife and I love our bull and branch eats
there's a reason that we bought them for
our kids rooms these sheets are just top
quality and again you shouldn't be
sleeping on a tarp that you got down at
the at the local retail store for an
overpriced amount instead you should be
getting bull and branch eats and
sleeping better tonight there bring the
bowl they had software overtime their
great bowl and branch calm promo code
been 450 bucks off your first set of
sheets go check it out right now okay so
the media continued to play defense for
Democrats take for example this clip
Nancy Pelosi's daughter and she was on
MSNBC and she was talking about or CNN
rather and she was talking about her
mother listen to what she says about her
mom and then listen to the reaction of
the anchors what are your feelings about
this person who you know quite well
becoming Speaker of the House for a
second time she'll cut your head off and
you won't even know you're bleeding
that's all you need to know about her no
one ever won betting against an supposed
she's perfect she's persevered
hahahahahahaha she'll cut your head off
and you'll never know that you're
bleeding
she'll disembowel you and you'll never
know your spleen is missing she will
cannibalize you and you'll never know
that you're missing your small intestine
and everybody's laughing look at that
the anchors ahahaha now imagine for just
a second that somebody had had on Eric
trump jr. right Eric Trump and Eric
Trump had been asked about Donald Trump
and he said you know my dad he can cut
your head off and you'll never know
you're bleeding would that ever stop
being a meme would it would it would the
bankers have reacted
with laughter or whether they have
reacted with shock and outrage that sort
of violent language cutting off people's
heads
what is he Isis what does he I mean
remember how nuts they went when
President Trump just tweeted out a crazy
meme of himself levelling a is a WWE
clip he tweeted out a meme of himself
levelling a wrestler who had a CNN logo
for a head you remember this and it was
the biggest deal in the world Nancy
Pelosi's daughter goes on national
television and says her mom cuts
people's heads off and you won't even
know you're bleeding
nothing what about all that violent
rhetoric talk where to go when the
middle of a government shutdown wouldn't
be better if you actually had a Speaker
of the House willing to come together
and compromise no let's all laugh about
it together that's that's the way the
media operate these days well meanwhile
with all this happening in turn a seemed
warfare has basically broken out in both
parties
there's internecine warfare obviously
inside the Republican Party between the
so called never Trump wing of the
Republican Party and President Trump and
people who voted for him and plan on
voting for him in 2020 President Trump
leads the charge in this direction now
as I've said before I think that when
people say never Trump they are they are
using the category too broadly I think
there's a category misapplication here
so there are people who didn't vote for
President Trump in 2016 those people
break down into a couple of different
groups there are the people who didn't
vote for President Trump in 2016 and and
they think that everything the President
Trump does both good and bad is actually
bad for the country because the better
president Trump does the worse it is for
the country because Trump himself is bad
right into this category when for max
boot Bill Kristol Jennifer Rubin
everything Trump does is bad whether it
is good or whether it is bad if it's bad
it's bad and if it's good it's bad
because it helps Trump right that is
that is perspective number one from the
never Trump category perspective number
two never Trump was a category of people
a group of people who said we're not
gonna vote for Trump in 2016 based on
the available evidence at hand because
we think that he lacks character and we
don't know he's gonna be conservative
right and we will judge him based on his
evolution and his actions on a day to
day basis right this would be people
like me I didn't vote for President
Trump in 2016 but I evaluate him on the
basis of is he doing something good or
is he doing something bad just like we
did on today's show we have been utterly
consistent since 2015 there's good Trump
there's bad from they exist in the same
human right all of this is true
so that's category number two so when
you are talking about the people who
over
say that everything Trump does is bad so
I think that we should actually have
three categories of people with regard
to Trump there are the always Trump errs
everything Trump does is good no matter
what doesn't matter right him him making
comments about Megyn Kelly's bleeding
wherever that's good because Trump said
it right those are the always Trump errs
it's like the Bill Mitchell crowd and
there are the number Trump errs
everything Trump says is bad even if
he's moving the embassy to Jerusalem and
helping to destroy Isis all that's bad
because it helps Trump and then there
are the sometimes Trump errs who say
okay here's what he's doing that's good
and here's what he's doing that's bad I
think the vast majority of people fall
into the sometimes Trump category
whether or not they vote for Trump or
not in 2020 they at least acknowledge
what he's doing that's good and what
he's acknowledging that's bad okay so
President Trump is taking on a group of
people who I think are rightly being
called never Trump pers meaning that
Mitt Romney Jeff Flake a group of people
who feel the constant necessity to do
ride pretty much everything that the
president does with the with the belief
that President Trump successes
contribute to the unsuccess of the
country I think this is the the subtle
message of mitt romney's op-ed yesterday
in the Washington Post he acknowledges
the President Trump has done good things
on conservative policy but then he
basically says all of that good is
undone and not only undone made bad
almost by president Trump's character
because President Trump as a man of
little character everything that he does
that it's good that Rhian shrines that
man in office is a bad thing those sort
of Mitt Romney's take in the Washington
Post well Trump went after Romney and I
don't think that this was completely
inappropriate here as president Trump
yesterday going after the senator from
Utah I was surprised at Mitt Romney but
we just hope he's going to be a team
player and if he was a team player
that'll be great I will say this if he
fought really hard against President
Obama like he does against me he would
have won the election does that make
sense to you if he fought the way he
fights me I'm telling you he would have
won the election okay that is the common
feeling among a lot of Republicans about
Mitt Romney which is why when Romney
sits on the sidelines and snipes at
President Trump about his character
without any real solution to it people
wonder okay so what exactly are you
suggesting
senator Romney same thing with Jeff
Flake right Jeff Flake has made a
big thing out of his disdain for
president Trump's character now again
I'm not somebody who's been kind to
president rubs character I challenge you
to find anywhere in the last four years
in which I've said that I think the
President Trump is a man of moral fiber
and character I don't think that
President Trump is frankly but that
doesn't mean that he can't have good
policy it doesn't mean that I can't like
a lot of his policies so when Trump goes
after flake right when when trunk was
after flake because flake has made sort
of the leading points of the spear his
argument that Trump is a man of no
character and then Trump says that flake
is gonna wind up on CNN again there's a
there's a grain of truth to this the
internecine warfare that's happening is
right now in the Republican Party not
between the sometimes Trump pers and the
always Trump or the sometimes Trump pers
and the never Trump pers but between the
always Trump errs and the never Trump
errs and here's Trump going after Jeff
Flake that senator from Arizona Jeff
Flake wonderful guy I never even met him
and he's hitting me
he was going to tell people how to win
in 2020 because 2016 Kent he wrote a
book about it didn't work out too well
that book because we won in 2016 because
we didn't want to wait till 2020 so Jeff
Flake is now selling real estate or
whatever he's doing you'll probably go
to work for CNN that's my prediction
some pretty brutal stuff there from
President front but again this is why I
think the international warfare inside
the Republican Party should stop being
so much about personality and start
being a little bit more about policy and
ideas this is why I think that the
interesting conversations are being had
inside these sometimes Trump category
because sometimes Trump really means the
Trump doesn't matter right sometimes
Trump means that we're holding Trump to
the same standard we hold any other
politician which is does he do good
stuff or does he do bad stuff if you are
loyal to President Trump
through and through and he can't do
anything that would alienate you in any
way then you're doing politics wrong and
if you are never at Trumper in the sense
that everything the President Trump does
is inherently bad then I would suggest
you are also doing politics wrong
because viewing politics and policy
through the lens of one particular man
is a recipe for narcissism for both him
and for you okay so in a second I want
to get to the Democratic chaos that's
been breaking out because it's not just
chaos on one side of the aisle the
internet' SEMA warfare or the Democratic
Party's gonna get really bad really
quickly but first you're gonna have to
go over and subscribe for $9.99 a month
you can subscribe over at daily wire we
have all
sorts of goodies when you do subscribe
for example tonight we have our next
episode of daily wire backstage Andrew
Clavin the execrable Michael Mills
Alicia Kraus daily we're a god-king
jeremy boring I we will all be here to
ring in the new year and of course
answer all of your questions as always
only daily wire subscribers get to ask
the questions so make sure to subscribe
today I mean I'm spending two additional
hours here today with you answering your
questions watching my colleagues smoke
and infect my lungs with horrific ash as
I suffer through a cold just for you the
least you can do is subscribe and for
$99 a year you get that the rest of my
show live the rest of Clavin the show
live the rest of Noel's itial address
and Matt Walsh your show live get all
sorts of goodies and for that ninety
nine dollars here you get this the very
greatest and leftist here's hot or cold
tumblers now I'm slightly less sick
today and I was yesterday why because
yesterday I sipped from this tumbler I
mean maybe that's why I I will I will
suggest that's why for purposes of
selling the tumbler but I will say is
that I went on vacation didn't have the
tumbler got sick came back starting from
the tumbler started to get well again
it's possible that if your father were
shot in a cave in like ancient in
ancient Israel and and your father were
were bleeding from that wound and you
found this tumbler in the cave and you
poured water from the tumbler on the
wound and your father was Sean Connery
that the one might heal and that's how
that's all that I'm saying to you I'm
not saying that the cups the Holy Grail
or anything but I don't know I mean do
you know what the Holy Grail look like
you don't do you
I know you don't okay guys go check us
out over at YouTube or iTunes please
subscribe over there a lot of great
Sunday specials coming up you're gonna
want to be privy to those as well we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so it's not just internecine
warfare on the Republican side of the
aisle and again I think the internation
aisle is actually less divisive inside
the Republican Party than the
internecine warfare on the Democratic
side of the aisle I think the
Republicans have basically come to a
pretty solid consensus about President
Trump overall they like him overall they
like his policies they made disdain some
of the things that he does or says they
may have qualms about his character but
overall the guy does have like a 90
percent approval rating inside the
Republican Party the same is not true
inside the Democratic Party and so they
are deciding on which angle to take and
right now they don't have an angle right
now they're just beating each other's
brains in it's pretty astonishing
actually so this is this is evident in
everything from their congressional
policy to the presidential race of 2020
so take for example congressional policy
it's it's very easy it's really easy to
talk about how you would run the
government until you actually run the
government this is one of the great
ironies of how party politics works in
our era so Alexis de Tocqueville is the
author of democracy in America really
the great classic on how America's
constitutional system was set up the
Frenchmen who toured the United States
in the 1820s and then went and wrote
probably the great tome in in history
about the United States he talked
specifically in democracy in America
about times in which parties are great
and times in which parties are small and
what he says is that when a country is
in crisis and parties are great meaning
that they have broad overarching ideas
that they're going to bring
revolutionary change and when times are
pretty good when times are not chaotic
then parties are small meaning that they
fight about personality and they fight
over small details and they seem petty
okay that suggests to me that while we
all think that we're in a crisis what
we're iliyan is in a pretty good time in
American history because the parties
seem to be pretty small and they're
fighting about pretty small things now
they like to pretend that they're
fighting about big ideas and big things
when it comes right down to it the the
warfare inside the parties inside the
Democratic Party inside the Republican
Party they're over relatively trivial
differences I'll take for example the
Democratic battle that is now broken out
over Pago budget rules so for those who
don't remember Pago budget rules
basically the rule of Pago is that you
are not allowed to pay your
not allowed to pass a bill that adds to
the budget deficit without a method for
rectifying budget deficits if you pass
an additional spending bill then you
also have to pass an additional tax bill
well Nancy Pelosi believe it or not in
the house is trying to push new pay gold
rules now you say to yourself why would
Nancy Pelosi want to do that Nancy
Pelosi is not fiscally responsible why
would she want to rein in spending by
requiring taxation to pay for that
spending don't don't democrats just want
to blow out the deficit the answer is
yes democrats don't care about spending
what this pay-go rule is actually
designed to do is to centralize power in
the hands of committee chairmen in the
hands of a centralized elite at the top
of the Democratic Party and also it's
meant to prevent further tax cuts right
that's what pay goal is designed to do
basically historically Democrats have
opposed Pago because they want to blow
out the spending and Republicans have
opposed Pago because they want to lower
the taxes well Nancy Pelosi wants to put
pay go back in place because she wants
to make sure that Democrats can't
propose crazy spending programs without
her approval essentially and this has
led to a revolt from inside her own
caucus so according to The Huffington
Post a small group of progressive
lawmakers are trying to derail a
fiscally conservative proposal put
forward by the incoming House Democratic
leadership one that could potentially
block votes on ambitious policy
proposals like Medicare for all unless
it's completely paid for the
pay-as-you-go rules commonly nose pay go
would require Congress to offset any
increased spending with equal cuts or
revenue increases elsewhere the
provision is contained in a larger
package of rules for the incoming 116th
Congress the fact that Democrats are
using their newfound power to stress
fiscal responsibility is baffling to
some progressives fiscal responsibility
was hardly mentioned in the 2018
elections or as big legislative ideas
were popular with voters
if leadership waives pay-go rules it
would allow free college Medicare for
all to come up for a vote on the House
floor and for the house to pass it but
that legislation would still not be able
to become law almost both chambers of
Congress voted to exempt it from
statutory pay-go a restriction enshrined
in law that leadership alone cannot
change there's already a statutory
pay-go rule that exists all this does is
it prevents a lot of these bills from
coming to the floor in the first place
it allows for more leadership control
which is why you're seeing people like
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez trying to vote
against pay go and stop Nancy Pelosi
from centralizing authority inside her
own party but the warfare that's broken
out inside the Democratic
party about priorities is really a
question of whether priorities should be
pie in the sky policy or whether it
should be governing Nancy Pelosi sees a
lot more practical as a lawmaker in
Alexandria Acacio Cortez even if they
have the same overall policy this
division is going to keep coming up over
and over and over and that division is
breaking out on the presidential level
in 2020 in the battle between Bernie
Sanders and bethe O'Rourke Bernie
Sanders supporters are ripping into beta
O'Rourke supporters right now there's a
real battle going on online between
Bernie who's a socialist and bado
who's kind of a quasi socialist why well
because beta o rourke is a more
responsible version of Bernie Sanders
meaning the beta O'Rourke has said that
he likes capitalism mater O'Rourke
doesn't believe that we should raise the
tax rates presumably to 60% across the
board the way that Bernie Sanders does
Ben bado supporters are being ripped by
Bernie supporters as insufficiently
doctrinaire insufficiently committed to
the Marxist cause Jonathan shade has an
interesting piece over at New York
Magazine talking specifically about this
he says the first skirmish of the 2020
Democratic primary a wave of attacks on
beta overworked by supporters of Bernie
Sanders took almost two everybody by
surprise on the outside it looks like
one of those inscrutable personality
driven online spats that characterized
the Twitter era but the feud is neither
petty no personal or irrational it's the
first shot in a war that may well
continue for the next year and a half he
says the Sanders partisans who are
attacking O'Rourke are not
representative of Sanders voters as a
whole Sanders attracts the intense
support of a small left-wing
intellectual and art who see American
politics in fundamentally different
terms than most Democrats - the primary
struggle in American politics as they
see it is not between liberalism and
conservatism but between socialism and
capitalism Sanders labels himself a
socialist he frames his rhetoric and
Marxian class terms Bader O'Rourke does
not and that means that the baito
supporters and the Bernie supporters are
really going to war with one another now
this is gonna take a lot of different
forms but one of the forms is gonna take
his baito supporters coming after Bernie
for Bernie's personal foibles so Bernie
Sanders made a big mistake yesterday
there's a story that broke in Politico
about how more than two dozen women and
men who worked on Sanders his 2016
presidential campaign are now seeking a
meeting with Sanders to discuss the
issue of sexual violence and harassment
on the 2016 campaign for the purpose of
planning to mitigate the issue in 2020
Bernie's
Anders was asked about it yesterday he
said he didn't know anything about it at
the time he was a little busy which is a
bad answer he just said I didn't know
anything about it we'll get to the
bottom of it but things are gonna get
rough inside the Democratic Party it is
easy to be the non governing party it is
much more difficult to be the actual
governing party and that's what
Democrats are about to learn in both the
house and they're about to learn in the
2020 Democratic primaries as well okay
meanwhile I have to tell you the
craziest Twitter story I have seen like
ever ok so my business partner
Jeremy boring it's it's really
spectacular he was suspended from
Twitter today why was he suspended from
Twitter because someone wrote a tweet
about a recipe for Brussels sprouts and
then Jeremy tweeted quote even better
coat with melted butter salt pepper
paprika and a dash of Worchester SIA
Worchester Shire sear in cast iron in
bacon grease for 30 seconds or until
brown then throw them away and burn your
face off with the hot pan because even
that would be better than Brussels
sprouts and you made a joke about how
Brussels sprouts suck Twitter suspended
him I am not kidding you
Twitter sends him a 12 hour suspension
why because they said that he had
violated their rules against promoting
or encouraging suicide and self-harm
they said you may not promote or
encourage suicide or self-harm when you
receive reports that a person is
threatening suicide or self-harm we may
take a number of steps to assist them
such as reaching out to that person and
providing resources such as contact
information for our mental health
partners if you are having thoughts of
self-harm suicide or depression we
encourage you to please reach out to
someone and request help
so Jeremy made a joke about Brussels
sprouts being so terrible that you'd be
better off throwing away the Brussels
sprouts and burning off your face with a
frying pan
and Twitter suggested that he was
recommending suicide or self-harm
because of the wide spate of people
across the United States who've been
burning off their own faces with frying
pans after throwing away their Brussels
sprouts this is patently in the same
stuff Ellen Barkin the actress from
Animal Kingdom by the way she is still
on Twitter and has not been suspended
despite calling for Louie CK to be raped
and shot that's totally ok but Jeremy
makes a joke about Brussels sprouts and
vegetables and Twitter suspends him why
did any of this happen why is any of
this happening the reason that all
this is happening in the first place is
because all of our social media monitors
are of the left and the social media
monitors here's how here's the way it
works and it works this way in terms of
boycotts and it works this way in terms
of Twitter suspensions or Facebook
suspensions there's a small group of
motivated leftists here is what they do
what they do is they monitor accounts
like mine or like Jeremy's or like yours
and then they find something that they
can take some fringe offense at and they
send it in to the arbiters the
powers-that-be and then they know that
the powers that be are already
predisposed not to like me or like
Jeremy or like you and then the powers
that be give the benefit of the doubt to
the person complaining and they suspend
you and that's the way this works on
Twitter that's the way that it works on
Facebook as well it's really ugly stuff
it's the way that it works with boycotts
- we've seen boycotts in the past
against Laura Ingraham and we've seen it
against Tucker Carlson on the basis of
really really weak sauce why because
what's happening is there's small groups
people like Media Matters or sleeping
giants and they have a list of like 20
activists and they send out an email to
those 20 activist and they say today we
want you to target X advertiser or we
want you to target Twitter or we want
you to target Facebook we want you to
send an email or a phone call it's a
customer service at these places
complaining about such and such a person
and those companies because they don't
want to be bothered respond by either
dropping their advertising or suspending
people or destroying their social media
influence or destroying their reach in
other words we live in a society that
takes certain things for granted one of
the things that we take for granted is
that we don't want to bother each other
but because we all take for granted
living in a society together with the
social fabric where we're supposed to
not bother each other because we don't
take that for granted we've assumed that
if somebody actually is complaining if
somebody actually is making trouble if
somebody actually is the squeaky wheel
they deserve the grease right we're
making a baseline assumption of honesty
and decency in our in our political
lives which is that nobody wants to be
bothered and you're a nice person so you
don't actually want to bother me but the
left does not believe like this the left
believes that if they can make a little
bit of fuss they can make the world a
better place by cleansing the world with
fire by purifying the world with fire
and so a Brussels sprouts joke is a good
excuse to get rid of my business partner
on Twitter a joke by louis c.k about the
parklands survivors that's a reason to
destroy Louie CK not his personal
behavior his joke about the Parkland
kids that destroying people on social
media has become a pastime for the small
group of motivated people now here's the
dirty little secret no one cares what
these people have to say advertisers
need to understand this undoubtedly
there will be calls to boycott at some
point me or anybody else and there will
be no boycott boycotts don't materialize
like that hey chick-fil-a there were
calls to boycott it you don't happen to
chick-fil-a it made more money because
it no one cared but people have to stop
being so scared of the small group of
motivated people and understand that
those motivated people have bad intent
and are not actually trying to police
decency they're actually just trying to
ram through their political point of
view on the back of everybody else's
apathy that's what's happening in social
media and that's what's happening in the
advertising sphere as well okay time for
a couple of things I like and then a
couple of things that I hate so things
that I like so over the break I had a
chance to read I hadn't read any of this
performance recommended by Andrew Clavin
the the Hornblower series by CS
Forrester and it really is a lot of fun
there are all these stories about a guy
who starts off as a midshipman in the
British Navy fighting during the
Napoleonic Wars and they're easy reads
they're they're written I think in the
1930s and that they really read easily
they've not aged at all and they're
they're great for kids have been great
for teenagers so go check out the
Hornblower series they I know they made
a BBC series based on the Hornblower
series I think it's pretty good but the
books themselves are really good Ernest
Hemingway was a big fan of them a lot of
great writers have looked to them as
kind of models of adventure literature
go check them out the Hornblower series
this one is mr. midshipman Hornblower
which is the first in the series okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so a couple of things that I hate
today this is an amazing amazing story
so there's a story from NPR about why
millions of kids can't read and here is
what they say they say that a bunch of
teachers were basically taught the
stupidest possible way of teaching your
kids to read so I'm lucky I have really
smart kids my daughter is not five yet
and she is reading
she can read long words she's she's a
smart kid but that's also because my dad
particularly was very instrumental in
teaching her how to read we worked with
her she knows how to sound out words the
way that you typically teach kids to
read is they have a couple of words for
those who have small kids they know this
already but there are some words that
they can identify on site that you know
as soon as they've identified it a few
times over and and then they can now
identify that words by looking at the
word and then there are a lot of words
that they can sound out and you have to
understand this is the real breakthrough
for kids is understanding that every
letter has a different sound and that
the combination of those letters makes a
different sound this is the way that you
teach kids to read but social scientists
were idiots and say this they decided
that that's not really how kids learn to
read instead the way that kids learned
to read was by guessing it meaning I'm
not kidding here this is what NPR says
according to this this one teacher named
Harper the according to the National
Register according to the National
Assessment of Educational Progress 32%
of fourth graders and 24% of eighth
graders are not reading at a basic level
fewer than 40% are proficient or
advanced and here is here is what they
say they say that a director of literacy
over at a school in eastern Pennsylvania
was assigned to find out why this was
person's name was Kim Harper Harper
attended a professional development day
and one of the district's lowest
performing elementary schools the
teachers were talking about how students
should attack Wars in a story when a
child came to a word she didn't know the
teacher would tell her to look at the
picture and guess the most important
thing was for the child to understand
the meaning of the story not the exact
words on the page so if a kid came to
the word horse and said house the
teacher would say that's wrong but
Harper recalls if the kids had pony it
would be right because pony and horse
mean the same thing hey Harper was
shocked because pony and horse don't
mean the same thing and what does it
kids do when there aren't any pictures
like you know in most books this advice
to a beginning reader is based on an
influence
theory about reading it basically says
people use things like context and
visual clues to read words the theory
assumes learning to read is a natural
process and there with enough exposure
to text kids will figure out how words
work but scientists from around the
world have done thousands of studies on
how people learn to read they've
concluded that theory is wrong one big
takeaway from that research is that
reading is not natural we are not wired
to read from birth which is obvious to
anyone who has kids they they
legitimately there's a certain point
where their brains have developed enough
where now they can read but before that
they have no clue how to read even
skilled readers rely on decoding people
become skilled readers by learning than
written text is a code for speech sounds
and yet this ill-conceived contextual
guessing approach to word recognition is
enshrined in materials and handbooks
used by teachers wrote Louise emotes a
prominent reading expert in a 20-17
article the tech contextual guessing
approach is what a lot of teachers in
Bethlehem and learned in their teacher
prep programs so in other words this is
the problem with these top-down school
programs you know that are pushed by
people who have no actual relationship
with kids or parents they can buy into
any dumb theory of how kids are taught
and then use those theories on your kids
and you won't know about it until your
kid can't read at age 7 okay it's insane
like you would know if you actually sat
and tried to teach your kid to read you
wouldn't know that this theory is
nonsense from from the word go but in
these schools you can get away with
theorizing and writing master's
dissertations in education on why kids
don't need to learn to sound out words
they can just identify the picture and
this is supposed to teach them to read
and you can get away with it because
real-world experience in academia do not
have to have any commonality it's really
astonishing and this sort of social
science nonsense has permeated every
aspect of our lives from questions about
gender where the science is very clear
that there are differences between men
and women two questions about IQ right
where people are now saying that IQ is
not a good test of intelligence no IQ
isn't a perfect test of intelligence but
IQ does actually measure some general
level of intelligence particularly in
areas like like fluidity and how quickly
you grasp concepts it doesn't have a
general it doesn't have a 100 percent
crossover with success in life IQ as
I've said before I went to a highly
gifted program in middle school you know
I got in there's a cutoff at a certain
IQ point I was above that IQ point but I
wasn't like leaps and bounds above that
cutoff point there were
leaps and bounds above some of them are
in jail some of them are gym teachers at
Community College's IQ does not always
correlate with success but then there's
a group of people who basically just
decide to throw out IQ as a measure
because why should we bother with IQ as
a measure at all let's just come up with
some bad social science and pretend it
doesn't exist
the bottom line is this common sense
generally tends to merge with the social
science and if the social science and
common sense do not tend to merge your
first instinct should be to question the
social science not to question the sound
of the common sense really you know this
is the the that does not mean that
social science can't overturn common
sense sometimes common sense is wrong
and there's there over history there
have been common sense notions about
human beings and the nature of people
that have been completely wrong and
social science sometimes has been helped
to overcome it more often social science
has actually been used to reinforce the
wrong approaches so I'm thinking for
example on issues like race where there
is a common sense approach that
suggested that racial differences matter
in an awful lot that common sense
approach was wrong
the social science at the time actually
didn't cut against it it cut in favor of
the wrong approach to common sense it
took people of moral fibre to cut
against all of that but in general as a
general rule if a social science study
is teaching something that you know to
be false then your first instinct should
be to question whether the social
science I'm not talking about like
science science like you know
mathematical measurements or something
I'm talking about the science of what
you know to be true about human nature
if it turns out that the social science
is suggesting something that sounds
ridiculous it's probably because that
thing is ridiculous and that's true
whether you're talking about reading or
whether you're talking about gender or
anything else where human beings have
had good experience with human nature
for quite a long time for quite a long
time okay well we will be back here
tomorrow to talk about all these and
more issues i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire Ford
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018